[Applaudissements]
prenez soin de votre super héros tout un
programme
là c'est moi au milieu je m'appelle
audrey ah koon je suis donc artus a fait
une super présentation de ce que je
faisais mais ce qui l'a pas dit c'est
que j'ai 42 ans que je suis mariée pour
la troisième fois et que j'ai quatre
enfants qui vont de 7 ans à 23 ans
moi je suis le pur produit de
l'éducation à la performance j'ai été
élevé pour devenir ou en daim romaine
mes parents qui étaient très aisément
voulait le meilleur pour moi est le
meilleur selon eux c'était d'avoir un
job qui déchire c'est à dire pour ma
mère un job qui me rendrait indépendante
financièrement
donc ça veut dire gagner beaucoup
d'argent et pour mon père alors lui
voulait que je fasse polytechnique ou
l'ena rien de ça donc j'ai été élevé
non ça et j'ai été plutôt sympa comme
fille puisque toute mon enfance tout ce
que je faisais je le réussissais donc
j'étais première de la classe je faisais
du tennis devenait championne de tennis
de la danse un petit rat de l'opéra du
piano c'était super et mes parents quand
tu nous inviter des amis à la maison me
demander de jouer du piano
alors moi ça me saoulait est horrible
mais je dois avouer que de voir la
fierté dans leurs regards faisais ma
soirée et justifiait de jouer pendant un
quart d'heure devant leurs copains
donc j'ai continué le j'ai continué le
système comme ça pendant longtemps j'ai
eu mon bac avec mention
et puis après le bac moi je voulais
faire de la psycho et mes parents m'ont
dit ma fille tu es intelligente
attention la psycho c'est pour les
glandeurs c'est ce qui joue au tarot à
la fac tu peux faire beaucoup mieux
quand même donc je me suis inscrite dans
l'équivalent aujourd'hui de ce qu'est
une double licence un double cursus en
droit français et anglais ça c'est
classe et j'ai commencé j'ai commencé le
droit et à la fin de l'année j'ai été
bien récompensés j'avais pas tout à fait
encore 19 ans et j'ai eu un bébé donc à
19 ans je suis tombée enceinte et là
comme j'étais wonder woman qu'est ce que
j'ai fait pour ne pas perdre la face
j'ai dit moi je suis hyper balèze je
vais assumer et des études et d'avoir un
enfant genre mères-célibataires nickel
c'est super c'est ce que j'ai fait et
après j'ai continué alors pendant des
années j'ai continué donc j'ai trouvé un
mari quand même ça faisait mieux dans le
paysage
j'ai fait un deuxième enfant un
troisième enfant en même temps que mes
études
alors j'ai des trucs rigolos de j'ai
failli accoucher dans un amphi alors à
la fac pendant les partiels enceinte de
huit mois ça aide quand on n'a pas
réussi
c'est un oral et qu'on arrive enceinte
de jumeaux et je détestais la matière et
s'arrête en drilles l'examinateur donc
quand même ça peut aider
et j'ai continué comme ça jusqu'à avoir
un joli diplôme de notaire
donc bon métier qui gagne très bien sa
vie et ça donne un statut notaire c'est
quand même un peu la classe enfin à
l'époque elle l'était c'était il ya
longtemps un peu moins aujourd'hui et
j'étais trésorière de l'association des
parents d'élèves
je m'occupais donc j'allais à la fac la
journée je m'occupais des enfants la fin
d'après midi je faisais les devoirs je
donnais à manger je les coucher et puis
après le soir je leur faisais des
devoirs et comme je m'embêtais un petit
peu dans les années 2000 c'était le
début des start up internet
j'ai monté le premier magazine pour et
étudiants sur internet qui a été racheté
par l'étudiant le magazine le vrai
magazine l'étudiant donc autant vous
dire que j'étais parfaite que c'était
génial
et tout ça m'amène à l'âge de 25 ans ouh
là ça faisait deux ans que j'étais
notaire collaboratrice et qu'on me
propose l'association dans l'office
notarial
c'est le truc qui n'arrive jamais au
bout de deux ans faut attendre huit en
dix ans pour que et là on me sert le
truc sur un plateau donc vous imaginez
bien le soir on fait la fête on débouche
le champagne la famille mes parents mon
mari mes enfants
et le lendemain matin je me réveille et
voilà ce qui se passe je suis cloué dans
mon lit je pleure et je ne peux pas
poser le pied par terre ça s'appelle un
burn out une dépression c'est un il
venait de m'arriver un truc archi génial
qui était quand même la consécration de
tout un parcours ou de réussite j'avais
réussi ce qu'on m'avait demandé de faire
et là je mets fonde complètement et je
suis une chiffe molle dans mon lit et ça
a duré des semaines ça a duré des mois
des mois où je ne pouvais pas
fonctionner des mois où à peine je me
levais il fallait que je retourne le lit
où je n'arrêtais pas de pleurer
et surtout je ne pouvais pas m'occuper
de mes enfants et ça ça a été très dur
et donc à ce moment là je me suis dit
ça sert à quoi d'être under your man ça
sert à quoi d'être de tout réussir et
tout ça et j'ai commencé à me poser les
vraies questions celles que je m'étais
jamais posé avant parce que j'ai été
dans le faire dans dans l'action et là
je me suis dit mais j'ai été le bon
petit soldat
toute ma vie j'ai fait tout ce qu'on m'a
demandé super j'ai réussi est ce que je
suis heureuse pas sûr un truc dont je
suis sûr c'est que je suis épuisée que
j'ai 25 ans et que j'arrive même plus à
fonctionner c'est pas normal parce qu'un
corps de 25 ans moi je pensais que le
corps bah en fait quand on est jeune
battant qu'on veut on peut on y va et
puis que ça tient hors balais l'avez
compris que ben même quand on veut
parfois on ne peut on ne peut pas et je
me suis aperçu qu'en fait en voulant
être le bon petit soldat m'agiter
complètement à côté de mes pompes
vous avez choisi une voie qui ne me
plaisaient pas dans laquelle j'étais
compétente mais qui ne me plaisaient pas
qu'ils n'avaient aucun sens pour moi
aucune
ça correspondait même pas mes valeurs en
plus et je me suis demandé pourquoi j'en
étais arrivé là et j'en étais arrivé là
bas tout simplement pour une chose est
tout à leur monsieur vous en a parlé
la peur et moi c'était la peur de ne pas
décevoir
quand on a été élevé qu'on a été le bon
objet celui qui rend fiers ses parents
celui qu'on prend en exemple les autres
parents alors c'est hyper culpabilisant
parfois parce que les parents des autres
vous prennent en exemple deuxième date à
vue à elle elle travaille bien faire tu
devrais faire quand même
voilà mais qu'on a été bon exemple et
qu'on est là le seul risque
la seule chose qui peut nous arriver
quand on est au top c'est de descendre
et de décevoir les gens qui croient en
vous et je sais que c'est pour ça que
j'en suis arrivée là
et donc j'ai arrêter les bêtises et j'ai
dit écoutez j'ai convoqué tout le monde
mais j'ai dit moi je vends revenir à ce
que j'aimais au départ et ce que j'aime
et au départ eh bien c'était la
psychologie donc j'ai arrêté le
notariale j'ai pris des études et je me
suis formé à la psychologie
traditionnelle et
dans mon parcours j'ai rencontré les
travaux de martin seligman entre autres
qui est le papa de la psychologie
positive et j'ai commencé à m'intéresser
à la neuroscience parce que parce que le
cerveau humain ne finira jamais jamais
jamais de m'émerveiller c'est les
interactions humaines
je pense que c'est la chose la plus
merveilleuse qui exige la plus complexe
la plus difficile parfois la plus
douloureuse mais la plus merveilleuse
quand on commence à s'y intéresser et la
psychologie positive c'est ce courant
justement de la psychologie qui est une
science donc ça ça me plaisait bien
parce que c'était des chercheurs c'était
des chercheurs qui faisait des études
donc avec un truc un peu sérieux quoi ce
n'était pas juste des théories même si
dans les théories ya des choses qui ont
été prouvés après comme vrai et comme
juste l'aca s'appuyer sur des études
scientifiques
et c'est cette partie de la psychologie
qui s'intéresse à tous les facteurs tout
ce qui fait qu'un être humain peut se
développer harmonieusement qui est
qu'est-ce qui fait que en dépit de ce
monde qui est complètement chaotiques ça
ne vous aura pas échappé quand même en
dépit de nos souffrances en dépit de nos
douleurs nous avons la faculté d'aller
chercher et mobiliser des ressources en
nous pour non seulement affronter ces
moments difficiles mais en plus pour
nous créer une vie qui est riche qui a
du sens qui nous ressemble et dans
laquelle on se sent à l'aise dans
laquelle on peut fleurir dans laquelle
on peut s'épanouir
ce qui est chouette c'est que les
neurosciences donc avec les progrès
techniques et l'imagerie médicale sont
venus infirmer ou confirmer des thèses
psychologique
jusqu alors et qu'aujourd'hui on peut
s'habiller on sait de mieux en mieux
quand même comment fonctionne un cerveau
on connaît au moins les les
fonctionnements de les mécanismes de
base et on peut s'appuyer là dessus pour
voir ce qui favorise le développement ou
au contraire ce qui peut ligne
est-ce qui peut le contrarier et nous
rendre complètement inefficace et puis
la psychologie positive est une histoire
de super héros mais une histoire de
super héros au sens philosophique du
terme c'est à dire au sens où les papas
des super héros
si vous regardez enfin vous êtes ça vous
dit quelque chose tous les films de
marvel les comics les super héros
quand on regarde bien et qu'on analyse
déjà c'est très petit qu'analytique et
il y a toujours ses pas juge je suis un
super héros pour montrer mes supers
pouvoirs et l'humain augmentée qui va
faire n'importe quoi et devient attirant
il y en a quelques-uns ça c'est la force
obscure mais sinon un super héros c'est
dans spider man que c'est dit que de
grands pouvoirs en jambes de grandes
responsabilités
yes je vois que vous le connaissez et
c'est important
avoir des super pouvoirs pour soi seul
c'est nul ça ne sert à rien et ça fait
de nous des êtres arrogant condescendant
et qui peuvent finir comme et tente
despotique avoir des super pouvoirs
c'est pour les mettre au service du
collectif pour rendre le monde meilleur
et pour rendre l'expérience de vie de
chacun
meyer donc quand on est un super héros
eh bien il faut déjà démarré par savoir
ce que c'est que si on a des super
pouvoirs parce qu'on peut pas être un
voilà donc ce qui est bien c'est que en
psychologie positive tout un pan de la
psychologie positive initiée par par
seligman et peterson ça a été de
découvrir ce qu'on appelle nos force de
caractère
donc ils disent ils ont sillonné le
monde entier pour aller interviewer des
gens et essayer de quels que soient les
cultures quelle que soit la religion
quelles que soient les opinions
politiques pour essayer de faire
ressortir des qualités humaines et
universelles partagées par tout le monde
et ils en ont ressorti extrait 24 il y a
il existe 24 qualités humaines
qu'ils appellent des force de caractère
et ils ont établi un questionnaire qui
permet de les classer de les
hiérarchiser donc quand vous répondez là
je vous aime il adresse c'est totalement
gratuit en vous allez en ligne vous
passez le questionnaire et vous allez
avoir votre classement de vos forces et
donc ce donc sa classe les forces les
cinq premières forces dans votre
classement
ce sont ce havre super pouvoirs c'est
les qualités que vous pouvez actionner
facilement sans dépenser d'énergie
s'avoue même savoure recharge en énergie
et c'est là où vous êtes bon et puis il
est intéressant dans ce questionnaire de
regarder dans le classement
les deux trois dernières forces sa sé
sèl c'est même pas la peine d'essayer de
les développer dans cette villa vous
n'en ferez jamais l'expérience
ok sauf pour là quelques-unes la
gratitude et l'amour ou là on peut
toujours on peut toujours s'améliorer
dans notre système français est dans le
système scolaire les forces et les
qualités les super pouvoirs qui sont
valorisés ça serait plus du genre
persévérance autorégulation rigueur
amour de l'apprentissage esprit critique
pour ne citer que ceux là
qu'est ce qui se passe si on n'a pas ces
cinq-là en top de not least on est voué
à échouer
bon c'est mort pour nous on n'y arrivera
jamais non c'est juste qu'on ce centre
est en décalage avec le système et qu'on
va pas être forcément tous les jours
valorisé par le corps enseignant parce
que c'est pas ça qu'on met en avant en
premier et en plus on est dans un
système qui essayent de remédier aux
faiblesses
plutôt que d'essayer de booster les
points phares c'est vrai qu'on peut
critiquer les américains ils sont
critiquables sur dans bien des domaines
en revanche dans ce domaine là et les ya
pas que les américains tous les pays du
nord le fond aussi sont dans le système
inverse c'est à dire qu'ils sont là pour
potentialiser les forces parce qu'ils
savent que ça prend trop trop d'énergie
d'essayer de remédier
de remédier aux faiblesses donc pour
être un super héros bien dans ses bottes
il faut déjà je vous invite à aller
faire votre questionnaire à remplir
votre questionnaire et après avoir dans
votre quotidien comment vous pouvez
utiliser vos cinq premières fortes et
vous verrez que votre vie va devenir
beaucoup plus efficace et beaucoup plus
sympathique
je le disais un superpouvoir un grand
pouvoir en jambes de grandes
responsabilités
la première des responsabilités quand on
est responsable des autres c'est de
prendre la responsabilité de son propre
bien-être et de son propre bonheur vous
savez dans les avions
quand on nous dit si lé masque à oxygène
la dépression en cas de dépressurisation
de l'appareil
veuillez et même si vous êtes accompagné
d'un enfant en bas âge veuillez vous
équiper d'abord avant d'équiper l'autre
c'est un principe de base
on ne peut pas aider des gens si soi
même on n'est pas en capacité physique
ou mentale de le faire
quelqu'un qui en dépression au fond de
son lit en burn out en épuisement gelé
vécu ne sert à rien ça ne sert à rien
sauf peut-être à agrémenter les journées
des copines elle même dépressive qui
viennent peut-être se rassurer par
complaisance à votre chevet mais hormis
sa scène ou alors si aussi à combler le
besoin des chevaliers de ceux qui ont
l'âme de l'infirmier ou du chevalier
pour venir essayer de vous sauver hormis
ça quelqu'un qui ne va pas bien ne sert
à rien ça ne sert à rien attendu
ne sert à rien pour aider les autres si
si je suis au fond de mon lit je ne peux
pas aider les autres donc la première
des choses quand on veut contribuer
utiliser ses super pouvoirs c'est de
prendre soin de soi
or prendre soin de soi c'est prendre
soin déjà de son cerveau et prendre soin
d'eux des pouvoirs qu'on a dans notre
cerveau ans aujourd'hui ont subi une sur
stimulation cognitive
on est agressé par nos portables
toussaint les adultes on sait pas qu'une
maladie d' ado moi la première on est
toujours connecté à regarder twitter à
regarder notre eu les mails les machins
ça ça diminue l'efficacité cognitives
moins bonne mémorisation moins bonnes
intentions moins bonne concentration ça
augmente le niveau du stress la pression
on en parlait tout à l'heure la pression
diminue la pression avec des enjeux de
réussite très très fort diminue les
capacités cognitives
donc c'est contre-productif plus on se
met la pression plus on vous met la
pression
- ca - ça marche alors la solution c'est
quoi pas forcément le yoga c'est juste
que je trouvais dommage très simple
c'est pas forcément le yoga mais c'est
de prendre soin de son corps et prendre
soin de son corps c'est prendre soin
déjà deux trois choses de base
l'hydratation et quand je dis
hydratation ces lots il ya que loki et
brad l'alcool c'est sympa mais ça ne
rate pas l'exercice physique
les grecs anciens avaient très bien
compris ça les péripatéticien ceux qui
voient là les péripatéticien faisait le
tour de la ville avec leurs disciples et
puis comme ça ils parlaient discuter et
tout ça parce qu'il s'était rendu compte
que ça marchait beaucoup mieux quand on
était en mouvement un corps en mouvement
c'est un cerveau qui fait plus de
connexions donc rester le enfin les
fesses rivés sur une chaise pendant huit
heures par jour déjà c'est une hérésie
c'est n'importe quoi déjà si on veut
bien mémoriser et bien comprendre les
choses donc de l'activité physique
bah oui bah puisqu'on vous n'avez pas dé
tous des yogas beaulencourt encore pas
encore ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que quand on arrête
il faut absolument à les bouger tous les
jours marché mais une marche tonique 1
c'est pas juste une petite promenade de
santé
enfin le troisième pilier du super héros
est dans une super héros en bonne santé
c'est de se sentir utile aux autres se
sentir utile aux autres c'est se rendre
utile aux autres et se rendre utile aux
autres c'est quoi ces elle est aidée
c'est contribuer avoir le sentiment
qu'on contribue donc c'est aider chacun
à son niveau à son petit niveau
pourquoi pour sentir ce qu'on appelle le
sentiment d'appartenance d'appartenir à
une communauté d'appartenir 1 to à
quelque chose qui nous dépasse et sentir
aussi de la gratitude et prouver ce que
c'est que la gratitude la gratitude ces
cantons à l'élan de dire merci
quand quelqu'un ou quelque chose nous a
procuré du plaisir et ça ça vient
stimuler notre nerf vague il ya un air
dans le corps qui s'appelle le nerf
vague qui lui est le pilote de notre
système immunitaire donc plus on est
dans cette attitude là de gratitude et
donc quand on aide les autres les autres
nous renvoie la gratitude et donc nous
ça nous donne aussi envie de donner de
la gratitude et de reconnaître qui est
chouette dans notre vie plus on se sent
relié aux autres en plus plus on
augmente notre taux d'ocytocine dans
notre cerveau le site hocine c'est
l'hormone de l'amour du câlin et de
l'attachement plus on se sent bien et ça
donne un sens à notre vie et pour
conclure je conclurai puisqu'on était
sûr il faut trouver un juste milieu
sur un grand philosophe qui s'appelle
monsieur miyagi
monsieur miyagi karaté kid 1984 il ya eu
un remake avec jaden smith hockey et
jackie chan
mais il disait pas ça jacket chaîne donc
le vrai monsieur miyagi
il disait à prendre d'abord l'equilibre
l'équilibré la clé si équilibre bonbons
karaté si équilibre mauvais fais tes
valises et rentrer chez ta mère compris
merci hein
[Applaudissements]